bene tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovissimo video di minecraft con lo
stesso nesi l'audio al massimo nessun
altro infarto
adesso me la lasci se sei un uomo oggi
ragazzi faremo una spedizione molto
carina perché io ho visto che casali
step è stata totalmente rifatta dal buon
march al quale io ho fatto richiesta di
fare casa quindi possibilità di sé march
è un uomo anche lui o miri fa casa anche
a me non è giusto o mi mette un'altra
campana va e meglio è la casa della
carità gasperi ha però la campana ion è
un requisito deve rimanere quindi andate
tutti a ping alle marcite che l'idea di
far casa e marci 6 detto schifani
commenta ma è comunque oggi faremo
spedizione standard perché comunque più
che ci stiamo concentrando su a
migliorare l'isola anche io pero casa
mia non ho più toccato al minino vedova
che immaginari faccia quindi è giusto
che io visto che non ha senso bill dare
visto che c è un fenomeno in questo
all'istituto altro obiettivo cioè a fare
una spedizione e vedere che cosa c'è
fuori dal villaggio di youtube italia
perché noi siamo sempre nel nostro
enorme spazio perché noi ma non andiamo
mai troppo fuori quindi io andrei troppo
fuori a vedere che cosa c'è oltre oceano
come in altri contatti tra ragazzi ok a
morire altissimo hai visto racconta
riguardano detto va letto il manga ti
posso sperare noi siamo pronti
all'avventura incredibile siccome il
cavallo di stefan non è agibile ragazzi
non si può andare di due su un cavallo
lo sai come si chiama il mio cavallo
la famiglia minareto ringrazio garibaldi
è un cavallo bianco è perfetto come
quello di napoleone esatto vero si
chiama garibaldi perché non è che non è
agibile anche coin giungla a muoversi
con i cavalli e più scomodo che questa è
l'umidità qui la vita difficile
infatti le case costano poco ma cosa
vuoi perché già vicino a l'aja e niente
oggi vi trattano tutti ma l'economista
che non hai i soldi e basta
e comunque ragazzi la o eccolo qua il
tempio il tempo perfetto l'ho ritrovato
e c'è già una barca c'è già arrivando se
c'è una barca arriva arriva
6 giornata lega che però non è nostra
abbiamo già saccheggiato un piccolo di
legno sicuramente la mia che non lo
voglia di buttarvi questo era il tempo
che aveva saccheggiato un sacco di
episodi fa sono cresciute le altre
niente adesso c'è già una barca quindi
ce ne manca una sostanzialmente poi da
qua possiamo andare oltre perché l'acqua
finisce tutta la lunga e fatta quindi
prendi con la barca stefano ok ma quel
che possiamo andare in due nella stessa
barchetta e ma veramente no da esso
gioco non è così sviluppato in 3d bar
salta su aspettava il bellissimo gioco
il diritto per andarvi rea dritto per
andar dritto tira dritto totalmente a
casa bianca ma lo sai che hanno scoperto
che dell'america ma infatti noi sia per
schermo la stessa cosa per almeno
mettere nei libri di storia cosa adesso
sul sito viola hanno fatto un altro
villaggetto è lo scopriamo così perché
e passiamo da un server all'altro
l'americano va bene e niente vediamo di
riuscire a raggiungere un
una riva perchè feliciano l'oceano io
volevo vedere cosa c'è oltre perché
volte non c'è mai stato nessuno
il turn ed esploratori io mi mangio il
pane mentre mentre 26 notte è un
problema e pero di tranquillo possiamo
dormire in barca e che mischia o sete
sperma ci seguono i delfini è bellissimo
c'è la ferma come io vedo solo la tua
testa c'è solo delfino che ci sta
seguendo e fischia bellissimo sinistra
simpatici ma ora mi guarda e la
bellissima desco ci siamo fregati
seconda dopo due ore e mata arriviamo
all altro capo del mondo qui adesso non
sappiamo niente e questo è tutto che
intoccato per troveremo dove popolazione
popolazione c'è un matinée immagini c'è
ci sono i doppelganger no se ci sono i
cattivi luce tipo i vol march che
distrugge le case degli altri vece di
farle dio santi ma guarda neanche quando
ho visto giorgio così tanti chilometri
ne è veramente orribile questa o villano
loro ed a un'ora che tanto c'è non l'ho
visto sono un pazzo incredibili c'è un
un villaggio villaggio questo villaggio
di villaggi credibile ok ok ok perfetto
perfetto effetto pazzesco ma limite le
tartarughe qua ma è vero meno vedo
niente loro perché sono allucinazioni
perché siamo datato nel deserto filo di
rame non sono vere sono fake e tanto
ferito il panel incredibile non fu
tenero dipinte china ormai televotate
prendi il pollo cotto non si sa mai
ok buongiorno buon giorgia ora ga i
beduini
vediamo se riusciamo a rubare qualcosa
tipo letto ma loro si incavolano solo
primavera no no no no allora sono
tranquilli codreanu e la possiamo
dormire in due a casa mia adesso è bello
è veramente la cosa principale
una segrete della casa hanno loro cibo
tranquillo ci penso io ho letto molto
più carina lo prendo
no respon poi set ho finito
ma se muoio riparto da qui e ho fatto
una cacata qualcuno aspetto che si
trovano trattamento è solo il 62
c'era una non posso dirlo perché siamo
family friendly però tutt'altro questa
casa l'ha capito tutti hanno capito
vabbé non importa chiamava il sole
bandai a sandra montando abbiamo poi
dormire allora ragazzi questa è la
tattica giusta abbiamo dormito insieme
nostri amici senza avergli intimato
nella loro privacy
però nessuno tra da niente quindi io di
legno andare ho preso praticamente tutto
è vero io volevo prenderlo predizione
preso due
e questo un pieno tempo stato e un sacco
il restauro banda della val cactus
sì ma quello in vasetto e poco carino è
il momento di salutarci amici grazie per
aver trattato nulla con noi siete lì il
t maledetti le scopo favola un cornuto
persone e village non li potevi rubare
letto vai con il insieme ho capito
conigli non hanno le pa veicoli nel
deserto scusa ma vivono lì probabilmente
niente di socio e li metto il coniglio
posso rimettere il coniglio per dare
niente scusa ho sbagliato ma che è
successo seguimi
questa è la cosa fantastica allora
allora allora è una roba che più non
conosci ti piacerà state proprio sotto
sott'acqua no è un'altra cosa
allora barchetti na così mara che esista
c'è un portale che ieri l'ha visto
no non l'avevo visto quello che ci
pensiamo allora non chiedermi come l'ho
vista perchè non avevo più renderli
stans di un chilometro perché io allora
sotto di te una barca è da itunes vai
dentro i suoi tesori rimedi quali ci
sono avere certe non ci credo come sia
fine eccola carote e rotte in flash
grazie mille all'ora o gli orange no
però cento deve essere di 6 3
è un artista
veramente i denti contenuti sono sì sì
no non la sapevo ma non ero così esperto
allora sono le altre due muri questa
questa questa quest'anno sto pagando
aspettano trovato un altro io ho
sbagliato perché torna ma sì c'è una
mappa del tesoro 6 2 6 2 6 torna sul
tema su si ferma su che mori allora
guarda è pronto vai qua sotto e aprì
questo senso nell'angolino è pieno di
roba ci dividiamo tutto via meda ho
preso tutti tele lapislazzuli viene che
poi giustamente tutti i vini che io
lapislazzuli di trovo veramente inutili
ma perché gioca a minecraft da prima che
ci fosse le incessanti e quindi era
inutile sostanzialmente prima di
lanciare si è completamente inutile
provare la barca e andiamo subito al
portale fantastico allora quando un
civile coperte fino se vuoi fare il figo
di melo a iniziare car
allora sto cercando lavoro in una cesta
c'è una cesta anche la cei a casa da
qualsiasi cosa incredibile
il si si si questa può avere quando ho
visto tante cose dorate in santa fe
dobbiamo dobbiamo dobbiamo partire
romano è la tua spedizione attacchi da
ahmed e atac sfida quindi per breaking 3
ottimo visto che a p2 armour e cus of
finding wii non lo posso togliere vi
pare va bene allora andiamo avanti la
saga veramente figo come comprerà
oltreoceano sono un sacco di roba come
perché nessuno è arrivato e quindi trovi
tutte le varie cose lasciate dagli altri
no lauren no non ci credo non ci credo
allora c'è un altro portale
ma quel suo nome ragazzi credibile non è
normale questa cosa si scherza roba
quindi va be ma tu non ti sembrano
niente mi di servizio tutto io va bene
lo diventi ricco
allora perché c'è una casa più bella
persona che di fargli l'elemosina
allora un piccone con seal touch che è
incredibile che ritieni piedi pieni
potuto nove aziende
e poi ci sono due franchise che vediamo
se a roma non è pazzo questo però
sbagliato ma email o accademia scegliamo
che è bravissimo andiamo andiamo al
quarzo che ci sono le rare le classiche
trappole da tiravo bravo mi spingo
dentro se fossi stato pietro che aveva
spinto si va poi esplode tutto 3 di
giugno ad una buonissima certo allora
bene per te perché siete un blocco di è
già stato qualcuno ma è impossibile no
no secondo me è un blocco fake
c'è un blocco di uno c'è un blocco del
gioco è normale allora aspetta che metto
delle torce magari che non si vede nulla
non si vede
non devi toccare la pace plate facciamo
che la spacca allora no mi sembra che
sia
calma poi prendi tutto ok aspetta che
non ho troppo spazio devono stare
mammamia celati eletti ma non esplosa
perché non mi conosceva no no mi può
dare
non c'è niente di sopra vero che non mi
ricordo mai dire no però io e controllo
sempre tipo nelle torri bisogna
controllare
non sembra invece poi il micro luca ci
sono 26 griffe e dato non è buona prova
cosa no per niente prove ecco eccoci qua
vedo l'ora perché notte quindi sia aiuto
uno zombie che se queste non ha colore
torniamo al villaggio ripiegare è alla
fine ragazzi nostri eroi tornano in da
house la tua casa a controllare
guarda la jacuzzi folli questa era la
più bella della casa ma fa niente
beh io gli ho parato il proseguito
ragazzi faremo il giro delle case che
voglio vedere che cosa stanno costruendo
di vedere se la mia casa successivamente
sarà l'altezza non voglio vedere quello
che è anche chang lo facciamo nel
prossimo ragazzi mentre torniamo in the
casa spero possiamo con cui guadagno
moriamo l'aqua a casa mia spalla e
procederà nei prossimi episodi
spero che mario maci tanto mi ha
risposto alla roma ma la macchina ha
risposto no doveva essere una sorpresa
volevo riparte il vostro gesto comunque
mi passati alla passione la faccia ok
bellissimo march number one perfetto
ragazzi sentiamo così abbiamo a casa
nuova quindi non mi preoccupo di
modificarlo tanto ci pensa magiche
extreme makeover march edition ci
vediamo un prossimo
ringrazio per aver partecipato
bellissima spedizione trovato 60 2009
una figata incredibile raffinato
incredibile e ti ruba jean harlow tav no
no no no fernando notte da allora
[Musica]